hunted by many warriors who wish to
claim the prize of her head many tried
and many failed turned to stone of just
a glance at her hideous face Medusa was
not always considered a monster in fact
it was quite the opposite she was the
only mortal of three sisters born to
four keys and seto two of the primordial
sea gods she possessed great beauty and
many men lusted for Medusa but out of
respect for the goddess Athena she
remained pure and she would eventually
become the priestess of Athena stemple
there were thousands who visited
Athena's temple just for a glance at
Medusa's beauty they even claimed that
her hair rivaled that of Athena it
wasn't long before Athena's jealousy of
Medusa became resent one day when Medusa
was walking along the shore she caught
the attention of Poseidon the god of the
sea and he was instantly infatuated with
her Medusa rejected multiple approaches
from Poseidon because if she wished to
remain the priestess of Athena stemple
she must stay a virgin Poseidon was in
the middle of a conflict of Athena and
he saw Medusa as a possession that he
could take from the goddess eventually
Poseidon grew tired of being rejected by
Medusa he decided that he will take her
by force Medusa in fear for her life
ran into Athena's temple in the hopes
that the goddess would offer her
protection there was no protection given
that evening and Poseidon had his way
with Medusa when Poseidon had finished
Athena did appear enraged by the events
that had just taken place she decided
that she would punish Medusa as
punishment against the gods such as
Poseidon was considered unthinkable
Athena cursed Medusa the hair that she
was once so envious of she turned into a
head of venomous snakes anyone who
looked into Medusa's eyes would be
petrified and turned to stone word
spread of the monster that Medusa had
become and she became the target of many
warriors who wished to add her head to
their list of trophies all that Triad
shared the same fate being turned into
stone until the hero Perseus son of Zeus
was tasked with retrieving her head in
order to complete the task
Perseus required aid from the gods he
was given a helmet from Hades that made
him invisible to Medusa a pair of winged
sandals from Hermes allowing him to
reach Medusa Athena gave him a bronze
shield able to reflect the gaze of
Medusa and lastly he was given a sword
sharp enough to cut off the head of
Medusa with all of these divine gifts
Perseus was able to behead Medusa at the
time of her death
Medusa was pregnant with the offspring
of Poseidon and from her severed neck
sprung the winged steed Pegasus Perseus
would use the head of Medusa to aid him
in several adventures and it played a
crucial role when defeating the Titan
Atlas Medusa is probably one of the most
misunderstood characters in Greek
mythology she's often regarded as a
cruel monster she had only the best
intentions and placed her trust in the
goddess Athena who ultimately failed her
and punished her for actions that were
beyond her control her story shows us
that even the gods are prone to the sins
that they so heavily pride themselves
above even in death Medusa can be seen
as a symbol of good as her head is used
as a protective amulet to keep evil away
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]